tonight we're hearing from the truck
driver who was brutally beaten over the
weekend by demonstrators in portland
meanwhile protesters are renewing their
battles with federal agents
correspondent dan springer has the
latest tonight
tonight portland police are wondering
where the next attack will be
last night it was back at the
immigration and customs enforcement
office
with dozens of federal officers inside
portland police declared a riot
after protesters started a fire broke
several windows
and threw softball sized rocks at
officers
we all should be condemning the violence
that's occurring
increasingly there are calls for
citizens to rise up and say
no more police chief chuck lavelle wrote
the solution is in a critical mass of
community and partners
coming together to denounce this
criminal activity and call it out
for the first time since his brutal
beating over the weekend adam haner is
speaking out
saying he stopped to help a transgender
woman who was beaten and robbed
but then her assailants turned on him
and his girlfriend i'm just trying to
make sure she gets in the car and i get
in the car and we both get out of there
and by the end of it you know i'm
wrecked and unconscious on the side of
the road and she's trying to figure out
what happened to me
haner says he was called a racist during
the attack police are still looking for
their main suspect marquis love
who reportedly posted on social media
while in hiding
defending his actions and asking for
money marquise love has an extensive
arrest record with seven
different bookings twice he was charged
with domestic assault
but the district attorney dropped both
of those cases for lack of evidence
a problem portland officials don't seem
to have in this case
brett dan springer thanks